The key issue when you're looking at
cost cutting is to always plan for the
future.
Uh,
the first set of,
of,
of questions ask yourself when you're
doing cost cutting is,
is relatively straight forward,
which is,
you know,
can you use the,
the necessity of cost cutting as an
opportunity to do pruning a trimming for
projects that aren't being as
successful.
Um,
but you know,
frequently though,
those are the easy ones.
I mean there's always some kind of
social costs internal to the company,
but,
but that's the easy way of looking
future.
Then the more difficult is,
is if you have to make decisions about
resource allocations,
about what you can apply to going to the
future.
And,
uh,
the algorithm or the,
the thought analysis that you apply when
you look at this kind of cost cutting
tends to be okay,
which of these things are most likely to
return the company to a very strong
position by which it can rigorously
invest in its future.
And so the projects that make it are the
ones that you know,
and those of course usually involve
people and resources are the ones that
you are investing in your future.
And,
and that's,
that's the key algorithm.
Look at him and,
and,
and whatever level of depth you need to
do.
You always looking to how do I rebuild
this thing into the future?
Managing risk is a key variable for
frankly all aspects of life businesses,
just one of them.
And one of the things that most people
do in terms of managing risks,
that's,
that's actually bad thinking is they
think they can manage risk.
Cause zero everything has some risks.
You know,
you drive your car down the street,
drunk driver may hit you.
So what you're doing is you're actually
trying to get to an acceptable level of
risk.
Now in economic crisis times,
the kinds of things you're looking at is
it's generally harder to get capital a
revenue growth.
Maybe more revenue lines may be unstable
or growth may be a less easy to predict
that you're going to get to.
And so,
uh,
what you do is you take a certain
conservative approach of when,
as all entrepreneurs should do you plan
for both good luck and bad luck.
You put extra time on,
okay,
if I have bad luck,
what do I do about that?
And that doesn't mean that,
for example,
you,
you planned that the bad luck of
certainly going to happen,
but you're ready to adjust your
strategy,
iterate,
uh,
interact and,
and presume that you have bad luck.
So in for example,
a financing circumstance,
what if financing is much more difficult
to get the new thing?
Do you have the contingent monitoring
points and the contingent,
uh,
you know,
I'm like,
okay,
here's what we can do in order to keep
this company going and build it into the
future.
Even if financing is difficult,
times of economic crisis can change what
the competitive landscape looks like.
Because when,
for example,
you have boom times capital's easy to
come by,
growth as easy.
Sometimes what you focus on is how to
accelerate in the boom during,
uh,
economic crises.
The question is the companies that come
out of,
you know,
there are sailing through that with the,
the best liquidity,
both assets on the balance sheet,
making money,
ability to grow their businesses,
get a disproportionate competitive
advantage.
So one of the really key things to look
at in terms of,
of crafting strategy when you're in an
economic crisis is how do you maximize
your look,
your essentially your liquidity position
and your ability to both take kind of
profits and revenues and in business and
then convert that into a stronger lead.
And so those companies can do that,
can,
can actually,
uh,
you know,
get a march on the competitors.
The key thing for all businesses,
and especially of course technology
businesses or businesses that deploy
technology as a key kind of strategic
advantage is you always have to be
investing in the future.
Uh,
technological change comes at
accelerating rights.
There are such things as,
you know,
Moore's law and that sort of thing.
And that kind of bubbles up into kind of
more feature sets and competitive
ability.
So the key thing is to invest in the
future.
And what that means is when you're
deploying technology or you're a
technology business is to make sure that
you're keeping on the innovation cycle
where you're,
you're,
you're both creating and adopting the
new business practices and the new
techniques in order to drive your
business the right way.
Now a really key thing in terms of doing
that is staying in touch with the people
in your network and in your industry to
know what the benchmark is,
to know what you should be doing in
terms of,
you know,
what are the tools and techniques
available and to be revving them as you
go.
And that is,
that is essential for B for maintaining
a competitive edge and being successful
if your business and kind of serious
trouble,
you have to make a decision about
whether or not you have a Sufi.
It's almost like on an investor or
venture capitalist,
the decision can you take the assets are
my you are and get to a place where
you're investing in the future.
And if you're not,
then you need to look for,
you know,
essentially,
how do you,
how do you mass,
how do you get the business to the place
where it can invest in the future?
One is sell the business.
Another is getting strong financing and
kind of reinvest in the business.
The way of doing that,
the key thing in any kind of guiding of
the business is how do you create a
strong organization that is kind of
accelerating into the future.
And when you're in trouble,
the question is what are the techniques
that you can,
you know,
Trim,
refinance,
soule,
et Cetera in order to get this business
back to that characteristic.
The CEO's job is always about
leadership.
It's about leadership on a vision in
terms of where you're going.
It's about making sure that people,
that you have the regular organization
and staff and that you have kind of
clearly communicated what some of the
plays are and what some of the goals are
in terms of the business and how do you
organize together in order to make that
happen.
So the key thing for a CEO to keep their
head in the game is recognize that those
turbulent times plan for,
you know,
bad luck as well as good luck.
Uh,
keep people,
uh,
focused on what the key business wins
are and,
you know,
provide the energy that people always
need in order to,
you know,
uh,
to go into battle because you know,
work is hard and go into work and do
that well and provide a good leadership.
You can for that.
In other words,
it's the same thing that makes good
leadership in any of that.